Ahoj, všichni.
Ahoj.
Dneska jsem zapojil do této schůzky
agenta pravdy.
Bude mi ověřovat, co se vám?
Schůzkách. A co si řeknete,
protože to odpovídá.
Trošku jsem se lekla, že nám bude hlásit,
jestli to je ale nebo ne. Co říkáme,
ale tak dobrý není to ještě detektor jo?
Tak za rok.
Ok.
Až za rok, to je v pohodě.
Tak ještě počkáme chvilku.
Kam tady Tomáš,
tomášův bod tady stále posílá.
Nějaké vysvětlení toma člověče furt to
posíláte ty jo těm KT ičkům.
No je to neúnavný zaměstnanec.
Dobře.
Pastore kohos vést.
Tak.
Vstup na to půjdem.
Martina se omlouvá to teďka zažehavá.
Už jít někde v hosíně?
Omlouvá a ten asi lítá kolem technologie
Filip mezibřický, takže Filip mně sdělil,
že případně Martina nebo Lukáši byste
sdělil něco o robotiku, respektive.
Dopravníku a podobně platí.
Jsem připraven.
Super Martina taky, případně?
Jo.
Tak jo.
Tak jdeme na to teda já promítnu.
A ten postup je dneska,
to asi v komornějším fóru.
Tak.
Rád bych asi doladím.
Dneska ty KPI přeskočil,
protože to vyloženě jakoby asi spíš
nechám na Hynka.
A já bych teda šel projektor projekt a
pak se případně do toho na nějaký na
nějaký věci, který jsem si tady vypsal,
tak když půjdu chronologicky, tak terko,
prosím tě,
tady se chci furt příprá zadání.
Máme teda to rozdělení zásoby v celé alze
tady k tomu chci říct něco a nebo.
Toto.
Můžu k tomu něco říct?
Ten projekt se rozběhl,
měli jsme schůzku v takovém širším fóru
už v širší skupině.
Teď tam jsou vlastně rozdané úkoly a
vůbec řešíme,
jestli je možnost realizace toho projektu
jenom, abych to uvedla,
tak my vlastně řešíme,
že na sezonu tu jak bych řekla nadzásobu,
což je CCA 17% objemu.
Jsou to vlastně je to čína,
jsou to privátky,
takže bysme přesunuli na Slovensko.
A teď je tam několik jakoby zádrhelů.
Proč nechci říct,
to nepůjde prostě nějakejch takovejch pár
překážek v cestě je potřeba vyčíslit 1
věc. Náklady za nějaký převozy,
protože aktuálně vlastně 60% číny zůstává
v Čechách, 40% se převáží na Slovensku.
Teď by se to vlastně otočilo,
pak tam máme problém VDPH,
protože u nás je 21%, na Slovensku je 23%,
plus se odvádí v jinej čas jakoby mnohem
dřív než u nás. To znamená,
přijde o část cache.
A plus příjem o ty 2% na tom DPH.
A je tam prostě pár takovýchhle věcí pár
bodů,
které je potřeba prostě projít a vůbec si
dát dát si na papír.
Jestli jsme schopni to na to Slovensko
přesunout, nebo ne? V případě, že ne,
tak by se řešilo,
případně nějaký nějaká hala.
Někde někde u brna je teďkon nějaké
takové návrh,
ale řeší se prioritně to Slovensko,
tak do příště se nestane nic,
protože další schůzku máme takovou
informační dvacátýho 1 5, což je,
myslím si čtvrtek a až to znamená,
bude to pod tomhle tý.
A pak tam bude důležitá schůzka povík
povíkendu. Vlastně,
kdy se nám vrací Hynek,
myslím si dvacátýho pátýho nebo dvacátýho
šestýho,
to znamená do příštího review se nestane
nic.
Tak.
Dobře, tím pádem bych to asi přeskočili.
Potom bys dvacátýho sedmýho května dobře.
Jo a už to nějakým způsobem běží a teďkon
říkám,
řešíme jak jak moc velký pro jak moc
velký problém.
Ten přesun pro nás bude znamenat IZ
hlediska.
Hlavně hlavně toho cashan no celou DPH.
A ten termín,
a když byste se rozhodli tam něco udělat,
tak ten termín potom nějakýho dokončení,
přesunu a podobně,
tak tam nějaký budoucnosti bude
stanovenej.
Co jsme se bavili tak na privátky.
Většina objednávek už je stejně
položenejch, takže by se muselo.
Muselo by se změnit a jinak bysme vlastně
Jas.
to rozhodnutí by mělo padnout co nejdřív
a bavili jsme se tak do konce do konce
června, že musíme definitivně jasný,
jako kam to půjde.
A pak to stíhaj jo no slyším si.
Slyšíš mě do konce června?
Jo ano do konce. Června deadline.
Červen červenec srpen potom jo já jenom
stahuju to k tomu 15 9 nějakýmu tomu
Jo.
termínu, který jsme si tady řekli,
že do tý doby se ty věci mají nějak
odehrát, že jo, nebo.
Jo,
ale teďko pro nás jako větší 1 věc je
Je to tak.
jako kdy,
kdy tady končí nějakej takovej
projektovej život a 2 věc je vlastně
položení těch objednávek pro pro čínu.
Jo, která je vlastně ten milník,
je mnohem dřív.
Jo.
No vidíš to, no dobře dobře, tak jo.
Super tak to je tohle to je.
To je nějaký jako rozebívací fázi a tohle
teda přeskočíme tak a jestli můžu rovnou
teda poprosit provoz LCO 24 7 koukáme sem
tak.
Koukneme sem tak tam vlastně aktuálně to
riziko, který tam je, tak je to closování,
co jsme řešili teďkon.
Už poslední měsíc proběhla schůzka s
dopravama. Čekáme na nabídky od gemu,
ty by měly být.
Já jsem napsala do konce týdne,
ale adam kyselka vypsal,
že zítra každopádně do konce týdne by měl
bejt nějaký cenový nabídky od gemu.
Máme tam ňáký návrhy,
řešení ale zatím nejsou vyčíslený cenově.
Tak to je 1 bod.
Řešíme tam aktuálně zase nárůst
distribuce exped czech z příjmu a vlastně
Aha.
převozy z chrášťan do do užic.
Proběhla tam nějaká diskuze SSPD,
teď mají termín do 18 5 na vyčištění.
Zase toho systému těch objednávek.
Psal mi Honza Horáček. Myslím,
že to případně v pondělí pak už vyčistí
on sám.
Takže doufám,
že to v pondělí bude dočištěný.
Každopádně tam spíš se bavíme s Tomem,
jakoby jak dál pro.
Protože mě to zatím přijde,
že dokud vlastně to SPD nikdo neupozorní,
tak tak prostě ten ten nárůst XPD bude
vždycky,
takže teďkon spíš řešíme jako jakej jako
funkční model nastavit po zbytek.
No.
Nechci říct toho života,
ale prostě jak jakým způsobem to
kontrolovat dál.
Tak.
A ty příčiny jsou známý,
teda ty příčiny kromě lidskýho faktoru.
I tak lidskej faktor je tam na v obou 2
případech.
Bavili jsme se o tom s Honzou lapáčkem 1.
Věc je, že je opravdu špatně zadaná.
Ta objednávka ze strany SPDA 2.
Příčina je,
že dojde jako k špatnýmu zalistování od
kvalitáře.
V chrášťanech to znamená dojde ke
špatnýmu zadání rozměru.
Toho zboží to znamená,
je to třeba tam i ukazoval příklad,
že to je zalistovaný jako VPOA pak dojde
tím. Pádem se vygeneruje objednávka na.
Na chrášťany a pak dojde ke změně vlastně
na XPO, ale jako to jsou jednotky. Jo,
já jsem ještě probíhala se standou žižkou,
jestli jsme schopný.
Si jakoby vytáhnout,
kolik kolik těch objednávek to je,
protože aktuálně tam máme nasměrovanejch
41 objednávek SXPO.
Bohužel nejsme schopný říct jakoby kde,
kde jako jaký procento z těhlectěch
objednávek je opravdu jako způsobený tou
kvalitou. Já si myslím,
že to jsou prostě jednotky,
že to není žádný velký číslo a většina
bude SPD.
Tak, takže ty příčiny by měl být tyhle 2.
Aha.
Jasně.
OK, evidentně,
je to nějaký přetrvávající jev no bohužel
Jo jo a bohužel říkám, já se bám,
že to nebude probíhat nějaká pravidelná
dobře.
kontrola,
že to vždycky k tomu tak jako spadne.
Jo.
Hele AA, jestli to chápu správně,
tak řekněme číslo 0 asi trošku jako
vzdálený nějaký galaxy.
Tak co je takový to to nejnižší číslo.
Pro nějakej drž holt pro to SPD.
Hele.
Když jestli jestli do toho,
můžu skočit my.
No můžeš.
Ano.
Když jsme začínali ten projekt,
nebo respektive,
než jsme ho spustili ty přesuny,
tak ta distribuce byla kolem nějakých.
Je to kdyžtak v těch KPI nějakých jako
zhruba 60,
70 job bline a teď jsme na třeba
dvojnásobku.
Takže jako na 2 stranu jako ty objemy se
mění jo,
Promiň.
takže jako poměrově to třeba může být
podobné,
ale jako na 0 to jako nedáme asi úplně,
protože jako vždycky něco uteče.
Takže je to takové jako takový.
Cíl jako že ta 0 tam jako to je jak
stoprocentní kvalita jo to jako chceme se
Jo.
tomu blížit ale.
Chápu.
Tak jenom poprosím tedy pokud tedy.
Tak říkám, to je špatně nebo dobře? Jo,
spíš jenom, že ta 0. Jestli víme,
že je úplně nereálná,
tak jenom si teda zhodnotit,
jestli teda jakoby to číslo nezměnit jako
ten tar get, co je vlastně jako reálný,
nebo s čím vlastně jako budeme happy? Jo,
protože vlastně 67 a pak za tím jsou
nějaký ty příčiny,
proč nám to osciluje takhle,
že jo od 67 až po 120 let dneska že jo,
to je tak jenom se nad tím zamyslet a
jestli prostě tady mít mnoho nebo něco
jiného,
nebo jestli tam vůbec mít nějaký číslo.
Enhnm.
A tam to jako tlačit,
no protože potom až bude ta bilance někdy
jestli sedneme,
takže jdeme tady 0 tady je 129,
tak to se úplně nepodařilo. Tak jenom to,
aby to bylo jako férový i vůči vám.
Jo.
Jo.
To, že nemá smysl tady mít nějaký 0,
když tušíme, že to vlastně jako nereálný.
A taky si myslím, že ještě o tom,
co nám vlastně až do jaké míry vadí,
že jo,
že třeba jestli 67 je to furt dobrý,
ale 129 už je třeba průser tak nějak asi
ta logika.
No to jsme řešili s Tomem,
jakoby jakej ten parametr vůbec jako
Tak.
No.
Přesně tak.
hlídat.
No jestli to třeba hlídat nějak na extra
na nákladech na dopravy,
na extra jako transportech,
protože to by ve finále.
No nic dobrý popojedem.
Jo.
Já spíš jenom 67.
Mám z toho nějaký potíže 129 12 způsobuje
Jo.
možná jiný potíže víš?
Třeba.
Tak jsem to myslel no.
Protože on je jako něco sou z Josef a
něco ještě jako vytížení toho auta. Jo.
No, no, no, přesně tak.
To je dokud jako dotěžuješ to auto,
tak ti jde jenom o ty storch line.
Když to řeknu takhle blbě.
Ano.
Tak mám, musíš objednat extra ten sport,
taky do toho padá ještě náklady za
transport.
Hele víš co já vyznačím.
Hodně, hodně jako nahrubo, no.
Chápu no, já jenom tak značím jo,
popřemýšlím nad tím,
případně až se vrátí hned.
A aby si to takhle tady nemá smysl,
nebo vůbec.
Co je teda jakoby ta únosná mez?
Já já si to dovolím doplnit,
ještě jsou tam více náklady za tu
Tuhle.
manipulaci v kráštanech že jo.
Jo jo jo jo proto říkám, jako je to.
Protože to by mělo přivést na příjem do
užic a tady se to potvrdí.
No.
Ano.
Když to takhle to vyloží v krášanech a
pak to musí zase naložit k nám.
Jo.
To je ta práce navíc.
Jo.
To bylo super,
to vyčíslit a dát to jako papír.
Tady to máte, podívejte.
Dobře.
No tak jo děkujeme míro.
Tak jenom todleto tady no myslel jsem to
červeně a zkuste to ještě prošťourat.
Pergo asi tady všechno děkuji dobrý.
Tak jo půjdeme teda dál.
Miku můžu poprosit destrukce technologií
a materiálů.
Jo tady to bude asi vyloženě ve
stručnosti,
Jo sorry.
protože se nic zásadního nezměnilo AV
tuhle chvíli nějak jako skoro finišujeme
podpis té smlouvy.
Je to ještě o nějakém připomínkování.
Každopádně malinko se nám otočil ten
seznam materiálu od inotechu k prodeji,
protože jsme říkali.
Minulý týden jsem avizoval,
že nebudeme dávat to,
co bylo určený k jehození,
tak se i no tech text se zase rozhodnul.
Po porodu s inventurama že to tam dáme,
takže seznam je zase změněný.
Rádi bychom dokonce ty nepodepsali
smlouvu a pak děj se vůle suplexu.
To je asi v podstatě všechno, jo?
A to je to.
Prosím.
Tady mám teda termín z minula od tebe
patnáctýho 5 je to reálný,
teda smlouva pro se smlouvu do s duplexu.
A ten podpis smlouvy,
no to říkám to říkám teďka jako do konce
tejdne, že bychom to chtěli podepsat,
což jako stále platí.
Dobře.
OK to znamená.
Já jenom jsem chtěl poděkovat,
že jsem likvidace nebo likvidace toho
bordelu papírového michale, tak děkuji.
Jo taky taky děkuju na ty říkala,
že už zas odvezli další náklaďáka,
Ano ano ano.
že snad už se to blíží.
Dobrý díky davi no takže za za tenhle
projekt asi všechno tam není potřeba.
V tuhle chvíli víc k tomu říkat.
A ten irotech nějak že se ten inotech jak
se jak se rozmýšlí a podobně tak to nějak
vstupuje do toho do těch do těch jako
procesí ten indotech.
Jako nemůžu vymáčknout.
Trošku jako trošku laxně do toho,
nebo k tomu přistupuje,
protože to nevnímají tak jako svoji
prioritou, ale jako ve finále. Jo,
když na ně tlačíme,
tak nějakým způsobem se toho dokázali
chopit a spolupracujou tak, že jo.
Jinými slovy tady vidím teda seznam
připraven jo to to,
Jo máme máme připravené,
respektive od nich máme 2 seznamy.
že to beru jako vernou minci.
Jednak to, co oni říkají,
že chtějí zkusit prodat a jednak to,
co chtějí zkusit,
vyhodit a necháme na suplexu po dohodě
sinotechem,
ze včerejška necháme na suplexu,
aby oni zhodnotili, co je prodejný,
co ne co jí ještě dává smysl do té aukce
dát, protože zase nerad bych,
aby se ta aukce nafoukla natolik,
aby nám trvalo to nafocování,
a to popisování v té aukci samotné.
Týdny měsíce.
Nevím kolik to bude trvat a abychom to
neoddalovali od toho kýženýho termínu,
Jasně no.
kdy 1 8 chceme mít všechno jakoby nebo
skoro všechno pryč nebo co nejvíc toho
Jo.
pryč.
Super.
Takže tak.
Termín tady design AU evidu někdy 1 6
cirka to platí teda.
No jak jsem říkal jako neznám úplně,
jak dlouho bude trvat,
než než to všechno narvím do toho jejich
systému. Ale zatím takhle si říkáme,
Jo.
potvrzujeme s panem vozarem z toho
surlexu,
že by to mohlo být toho 1 6 jo tam to
záleží na x dalších věcech oni potom,
Jo jo jo chápu.
co podepíšem smlouvu, tak jsem říkal,
že nám určí nějakého člověka,
který přijede do skladu.
Všechno to bude zkoušet nafotit,
bude to zkoušet popsat pro tu aukci a než
tohleto všechno dodělá,
můžu mu to chvilku trvat a já nevím,
jestli s tím bude mít,
nebo v rámci toho bude mít souběh ještě s
jinými svýma firmami.
Který musí dostat do tý aukce a tak dál.
Jo ale zatím říkám,
Jo.
že toho 1 6 stíháme nejspíš.
Dobře, dobře, dobře.
Jo a tady to je až v srpnu vyčištění
skladů dobře, no tak jo,
tady asi teda nic děkuju miku,
děkuju krásný.
Taky dík.
Tak Michala přeskočíme,
my se tady ještě nemáme.
Marťu taky.
Lucko prosím tě jdeme na tebe výtlak přes
10000 storjoins autostore.
Ano.
Tak.
Já vezmu kdyžtak svoje témata a potom
kdyžtak Lucka vezmu svoje témata co se
Tak jo, podělte se to nějak logicky no.
týče mých témat,
já tam mám já tam mám 2 velký věci,
který se udály nebo který se dějí.
1 velká věc je,
že s autostorem aktuálně finishem
přípravu na autostore discovery happering.
Jedná se o to,
že spojíme s ostatními s ostatními
zákazníky autostoru a budeme s nimi
sharovat naše zkušenosti a znalosti,
zatímco oni budou sharovat jejich.
Cílem je cílem, je nasát,
co všechno se může kolem autostoru dít,
v čem ještě zaostáváme? V čem jsme napřed?
A jak může mít řekněme nejlepší autosto
na světě? To je jako nějakej cíl,
kam se chceme dostat.
Mělo by se to ujít někdy v červnu.
Čili teďka finišim nějaký ty základní
přípravy k tomuhle eventu,
to je 1 velká věc a 2 velká věc jako
taková z provozu jsme koukali na ty
úpravy inboundů, který jsme dělali.
Co se týče,
co se týče úpravy chování v rámci toho
příjmu, jak se příjmu chováme,
jak otvíráme porty a tak dále.
Zatím to vypadá,
že tam je nějaký 20 procentní nárůst full
putu na příjmu.
Takže velice pozitivní zprávy ohledně
tohohle budeme to ještě dál sledovat,
případně dál ladit zase nějaký 2 velký
věci,
který se ten týden jako udály z mýho
pohledu.
OK.
Tady teda ono říct tohle třeba.
To co tam je napsané,
to jsou všechno víceméně starší věci.
Proto to proto to neprezentuju jo.
Jo.
Jo chápu chápu, já pak mám půlce prosbu,
tak lucko, já ti dám ještě slovo,
než budu mít tuhletu prosbu.
Jestli teda Martin je hotový?
Jo, to se jako ty hlavní věci jsem řekl.
Tak.
Ano.
Tak co se týče té části nákup a instalace,
tak.
Vlastně teďka máme odsouhlasený
harmonogram prací s elementem.
To jsme si odsouhlasili v pondělí,
takže si tam můžeš odškrtnout jedenáctýho
Milník, jasně.
5 milník hotovej ano.
Err máme ano,
máme nějaké cenové nabídky na na prostupy
Dám tu zeleninu už jo dobrý.
K.
od promanů na úpravy SHZKPSA ještě čekáme
na elektro a na data.
Ano.
Čekáme na nabídku od miry,
komu a budeme budeme dělat tender na
základě těch informací,
který jsme se dozvěděli vlastně v pondělí,
Jasně, jasně.
Ano.
že s miry comem úplně není.
Ano ano.
Doporučený spolupracovat nebo jenom
spolupracovat tak.
Tak budeme budeme dělat tendr a budeme to
porovnávat právě s těma cenama. Co nám,
co nám dá mirico,
takže to budeme brát jako k oběrnou minci.
Takže to je tak nějak?
To je tak nějak té stavební připravenosti.
Za mě to běží s elementem jsme sladění
pravidelně na schůzkách,
to řešíme a žádný teďka blokace,
nebo žádný rizika tam nevidím.
No a já se zeptám jo.
Ano.
Tady se mi dashboardu ukázalo krásně z
tvýho statusu.
Co ten proman člověče ten nástup toho
Romanu?
Tam.
Riziko,
že by nastoupilo až někdy na konci června,
to ten pozdní nástup Romanu copak to je?
No já jsem to z toho statutu statusu
smazala, ale když už jsi to viděl,
tak vlastně to je o to, že my jsme chtěli,
aby Roman nastoupil v červnu,
No.
aby se stihla ta stavební připravenost do
konce června.
Ale nicméně co je poslední informace,
tak on nemá jako dostatečnou kapacitu na
ty montážníky,
takže by mohl nastoupit na konci června.
Řešíme to s nima aktivně,
snažíme se na ně tlačit,
ale i tak to nevidím jako riziko.
Protože vlastně element potřebuje sice mé
stavební přípravu,
ale on začíná v těch 1 týdnech.
V červenci začíná s nabíječkama a začíná
s robotama a vlastně k těm portům se
dostane až někdy v půlce července nebo ke
Jo.
konci července,
takže tam eště jakoby máme relativně
buffr na na ten proman,
i když by začal na konci června,
takže proto sem to z toho smazala,
a protože vlastně jakoby je to takový
jako potenciální riziko,
ale zatím to není riziko.
Zatím tam máme dostatečnej buffer a
aktivně aktivně jsme to s elementem
Hele.
řešili oni,
případně i můžou prohodit vlastně to,
že nebudou začínat s těma portama v
tunelu,
ale začnou s těma portama na západě,
takže bysme tam dostali ještě jako víc
času pro ten proman,
že to jako není pro ně problém.
Super.
Jo.
Tyhlety jako zdánlivě rizika neboli
hrozby, co se tam stane,
protože už to je třeba. Nevim,
Roman vám to zmínil a logicky moc s tím
teoreticky může,
může prostě vytvářet svý nějaký alibi
jako jo.
Speciálně u romannu bych byl velmi
opatrnej,
takže bych tam normálně vrátil zpátky.
To není nic proti a trekoval bych si to.
Pokud se to nastane, tak je to super.
Pokud to tak ty máš ještě vlastně půlku
května, nějakým způsobem,
možná půlku června, nějak jako reagovat.
U čipu romanů jo.
Že bych si to jako tam nechal AA hlídal
bych si tohleto speciálně v případě
promanu?
Já chápu,
že se to dá jakoby ty práce nějak jako
přeorganizovat ale ale.
Byl bych opatrný, nenechal bych,
nechal bych tam.
Jako jak říkáš, je to hrozba,
ale momentálně nás to jakoby neohrožuje
na to.
Abysme měli tu stavbu jako dokončenou.
Já to chápu a trich 1 6.
Víme o tom, víme o tom.
Komunikujeme to s elementem element o tom
ví,
takže na případný jakoby změny toho s čím
Jo.
začne, tak jakoby na to připravenej.
Jo v pohodě, v pohodě mě se líbí,
že máte alternativní plán, to je super.
Nicméně i přesto bych poprosil zkusit to
na něj jako evidovat.
Protože se zkušenosti historicky
spromanem, jak se s nima spolupracovalo?
Tak to je 1 taková věc, takže mi to je,
že mi to jako nezmizelo.
Rozumím, rozumím.
Já to tady mám a 2 věc tady prosímtě,
mám pro příště ten status,
jestli by jsi mohla odmazat ty věci,
který už byly hotový,
protože ona nám tady bobtná,
že jo bobná a ty to nějak tady tučně
tučně tady označuješ,
co se událo nebo tak? Takže prosím tě,
já tě chci poprosit,
jestli bys tam vymazala věci,
který už jsou hotový?
To už víceméně jsme si 1 řekli,
tak nemá smysl to znova opakovat.
A dej tam vždycky jenom.
Jasně, zeštíhlit to chápu.
No a teď tam prostě,
když tam prostě jenom věci,
který se reálně staly od minulý středy,
nebo od tý přecházející schůzky, jo,
aby tam,
aby tam toho bylo prostě jako míň a jenom
to, co se reálně stalo.
Již se nestane nic, to to vůbec nevadí.
Jako řekneš, hele, makáme,
děláme nic se reálně nestalo,
to je v pohodě jako jo,
ale aby tam nebyla takováhle,
prostě literární jako sloh jo to nikdo
asi úplně jako číst nechce. Jo,
poprosím tě.
Dobře dobře.
To je trošku s tím.
Příště, příště to bude kratší.
No děkuju jo takhle doporučení jinak tady
teda milníky asi.
Asi tady není nic dobrý, tak jo,
děkuju tady asi.
No tam se nám,
tam se nám blíží ten milník na schválení
stavební přípravy.
My jsme to vlastně řešili s mírou v
pondělí.
No.
Vlastně všechny ceny budu řešit s Pavlou
a.
Děkuji.
Myslím si, že bysme to do toho pondělí.
Měli měli nějak zvládnout.
Jo.
Hele kdyby ne tady je osmnáctýho 5,
kdyby ne, tak měli,
prosím tě v pondělí vědět,
protože ve středu a ten status.
Určitě by to, když by se to podařilo,
tak by to mělo zaznít přesně jako 1 z
věcí,
který jste byli schopni jako odbavit,
že jste to jako udělali,
že máte schváleno?
Jo.
Až mi řekni, prosím tě,
ty se teda ještě tam se asi nevim,
jak potom plánuješ tu tu schvalovačku s
mírou rovnou?
Až budete mít nějaký ceny, tak.
Co extra.
Tak já jsem se,
já jsem vlastně pochopila IZ toho,
co říkal míra, že až budeme mít ceny,
takovou máme hodit razítko do konzole.
Super.
Případně do chatu a on se na to podívá,
když bude mít nějaké dotazy,
To jo.
tak se doptá případně,
případně se nějak sejdeme.
Tam si jako myslím,
že není úplně asi potřeba čekat.
Na ten pondělní by vykly meeting.
Co co vlastně máte?
Není, není, není, není.
Není a jenom prosím tě tady tady do forat
nějaký výstup,
teda od míry a jestli by jsi nasdílela,
co jsem k tomu řekl?
Připraven,
aby všichni si jako případně odnesli
nějakou zkušenost.
Z toho pondělka.
Čili jsi odešla.
No s tím,
že ta cena co teďka je jako od promanu,
tak je o nějakých 100000 vyšší než byla,
než byla jako loni.
Takže jestli jsme to konzultovali vlastně
s Pavlou a.
Měli bysme nějakým způsobem zkusit na
proman zatlačit,
i když moc tam nemáme manipulačního
prostoru,
protože nikdo jinej než proman to dělat
nemůže.
A navíc ještě proman mám v nabídce,
že pod objednání potřebuje dalších 5
týdnů na materiál. Takže jako to.
Taky pak je jako riziko na to,
aby mohl začít.
5 tejdnů jo OK.
No.
To znamená,
že vlastně no ne tak no počkej.
Takže vlastně logicky, když.
Nevim,
jestli to třeba tady někde v ideálním
případě schválí,
řekněme tady 2 třeba dvacátýho,
takže už počám. 1 2.
3 4 5 takže šestadvacátý dost ten
materiál, že jo.
Takže stejně to prostě vychází.
Nakonec toho června, jako my jsme s nima,
No vidíš to no.
my jsme s nima se snažili to stáhnout
třeba o týden,
že jo oni tam mají jako buffer,
aby prostě oni byli krytý.
Oni jako reálně říkaj,
že to prostě bude něco mezi 4 5 tejdnama
že to jako nemusí bejt jako 5 tejdnů jo,
ale prostě to, dokud to pořád jako nevíme,
Tak to jsme furt tady jo někde.
no.
To jsme furt někde tady,
no tady 2 celkem dvacátýho června jako.
Takže já jsem si z toho odnesla s mírou,
že všechno všechno musí jít přes Pavlu,
i když to jsou nějaký jako malý částky,
bude se to porovnávat u těch dodavatelů,
který jakoby známe ze Slovenska nebo z
loňska,
tak se to bude porovnávat s těma cenama a
potom prostě klasický razítka
schvalovačky v konzoli.
Chápu chápu, kolik říkali na tu změnu,
kolik potřebujou tejdnu nebo času?
Hele oni tvrdí,
že potřebují 2 až 3 dny na 1 port portů
je 5,
takže oni si napsali 12 až 15 pracovních
dnů. Nedělají víkendy,
takže my jsme počítali v tom harmonogramu
3 týdny.
3 týdny ještě.
Dobře no.
Enhnm.
Takže znova poprosím,
dejte si to jako nějakou hrozbu,
kdyžtak poslouchám tak.
Radši bych si to evidoval.
Dobře.
Jo.
Tak jo tak osmnáctýho 5 měli třeba vědět
nebo úterý 19 jako bez případně termín,
tak nebo jak to, jak to?
Jak to potom tam s tou cenou bude?
Tak jo.
Tam, jak říkám, jako cenovky máme jediné,
co nemáme elektro a it,
ale tam to jako úplně.
Jo.
No spíš jde o to, spíš jde o to,
že vlastně.
Tam můžu postupně odvolat,
ne pro vás schválit elektrika,
schválit ne to nemusí jako balíček.
Jo jo určitě.
Že.
Jo jo OK.
Dobře tak jo, tady asi k tomu nemám nic.
Tady asi všechno děkuji.
Tak.
Mani poláčky překročime v tomhle výro,
aby nám dal status.
No vidíš to Lucku na vaší kapacity příjmu.
Další téma tady.
Já tam status nemám,
ten jsem nestihla napsat ale.
Ale ale povídej.
Tady máme,
podívej zrovna dneska termín hele.
Řeknu to,
řeknu to jako krátce layout s dip je ve
finále ještě není dokončený,
ale vý tak ho finalizuje.
To znamená.
Stejně tak laur pro BPO stanice,
ale nicméně stihl mi dodat počet,
že teďka máme 6 BPO stanic budeme chtít
jich mít 10, takže potřebujeme přidat 4,
takže s tím bude souviset schválení
hardwaru na ty stanice.
AS tím layoutem BP stanic až ho dodá,
bude souviset i nějaká ta příprava té
infrastruktury,
aby jsme mohli ty stanice přesunout.
Co se týče toho otočení výtahu,
tak tam jsem dostala od robotalu cenovku
395000 za otočení výtahu.
Když jsem si to porovnala s nabídkou
loňskou, já úplně přesně nevím,
jestli se tam řešilo to samé,
ale dostal jsem informaci,
že u jižního sourtu se řešilo taky
No.
otočení toho paletovýho výtou,
tak tam ta částka byla 390 nebo?
99 takže o nějakých skoro 100000 jako míň,
takže tam mi to přijde docela napálený.
Úlet.
A víceméně,
když jsme se nějak jako s vítkem bavili,
tak on by byl pro to ne neotáčet a víc by
investoval do vybavení těch BPO stanic.
Takže zatím.
Zatím ještě jsme to jakoby nikde neřešili
dál, neřešili jsme to s Davidem,
neřešili jsme to s Ondrou,
ale jenom tak jako krátce jsme se o tom
bavili s vítkem a vlastně co.
Stanovisko je zatím jako takhle.
Terko,
prosím tě to správně k tobě viď ten výtah
tenkrát to jste nějak zamázli, že jo,
nebo jste se rozhodli to nedělat, viď?
Si myslím, že jsme to nedělali.
A ten důvod byl nevíš netušíš,
nepamatuješ si.
Nepamatuju si, dohledala bych.
Spíš jako jako koncepčně, nebo spíš jenom,
že to bylo drahý, zajímavý.
Přiznám ne, ne,
ne Jakub vocená dohledala bych já to
dohledám, nepamatuju se.
Jo jo jo dobře. No no pěkný,
tak tady teda lucko, prosím tě,
jestli byste napsal ten status tady?
Čerstvý jo.
Dopíšu, dopíšu.
Abychom,
abychom to pro knihovnika měli a pro ten
dashboard a zároveň tedy.
Dneska je třináctýho, tak co s tímhle?
Já vím.
Co co s tímhle teda co?
Ve finále,
tohle je takový jako pro mě vágný, co?
Já nevím, co ti na tom mám říct, říkám,
s vítkem jsem v kontaktu.
Dneska jsem s ním mluvila a říkal,
že to finalizuje, že ve zdibech byl,
že si to,
že to jenom potřebuje dát na papír,
ale nicméně jsme se domluvili,
že větší prioritu teďka má ten layout na
BPO stanice,
protože nám to souvisí s tím přesunem.
Dobře, tak.
Jestli už prosit.
Kdy se můžu znovu ozvat zejtra po v pátek,
kdy mi řekneš víc, řekni si.
Říkám to na tobě.
No přemejšlím víte je teďka na depu,
tam bude celou noc zítra. Nevím,
jestli něco udělat tak v pátek.
Dobře já se v pátek ozvu ohledně toho
layoutu jo,
bude toho stanic a toho a dvacátýho 5 na
rozhodnutí o posunutí výtahu to necháme
Dobře.
dvacátýho jo zatím.
Dobrý.
Já si tak jako když když bez jako
konzultace jako říkám s Ondrou s Davidem,
tak já si jako myslím,
že to asi posouvat jako nebudeme, ale.
Celé tého 5 dobře.
Že jako domluvit. Jinak Vítek říkal,
že připraví na obě varianty layoutu,
jak by vypadal s otočením,
jak by vypadal bez otočení?
Jestli vlastně je to pro nás tak jako
klíčové v tom procesu to otočit, nebo ne?
Dobře.
Jasně, no ale OK 20 nějaký týden,
tak tady ještě máte na tyhlety 3 věci,
2 věci, ještě čas jo.
Takže příště bychom si.
Já si myslím,
že to otočení mělo bejt spíš jenom jakoby.
Uživatelsky, příjemnější,
ale nějakou přidanou hodnotu výkonnosti z
mýho pohledu to mít nebude a za tyhlencty
prachy.
Ani omylem.
No to si právě myslím jako taky.
No ale říkám,
ještě jsem to jako nekonzultovala s nikým
jiným než s vítkem.
A když se neposune a nic se nám to
nezpůsobí, budeme v pohodě,
když to neposuneme.
Já si myslím, že úplně v pohodě,
protože my jsme s tím původně jakoby jako
napadlo nás to, ale jenom,
když jsme právě zjišťovali,
kolik to stálo předtím,
tak to byla raketa povedán ty jo,
jako je to uživatelsky příjemný,
ale kdyby nám to dalo, já nevím něco,
navíc jo,
jak to zvýšení výkonu nebo efektivity
nebo cokoliv,
tak jako bych o tom začal uvažovat,
ale v tuhle chvíli jakoby souhlasím s
víkem,
Jo.
že radši ty prachy narvu do toho vybavení.
Tam, aby to bylo uživatelsky příjemnější,
protože tam si myslím, že jsme schopný.
Potom díky tomu mít nějaký lepší výsledky.
Souhlas.
Jo s tím taky souhlasím no.
Tak to je jasná zpráva OK dvacátýho 5.
Prostě tohle a potom buďto ano nebo ne.
Jo myslím,
že by se míra ptal asi na to samé.
Tak jo dobře, jo,
tak jenom prostě tu Lucku dopisnu status
a tady v pátek já se znova připomenu na
tyhlety 2 věci tady ty 2 lauta BPO jo.
Dobře doufám,
že pro tebe budu mít pozitivnější zprávu
v pátek.
No budeš proměnit určitě nějakou zprávu.
No tak doufám, doufám, že bude pozitivní.
Že jo.
OK dobře.
Pokud tak jo, děkuju lucko teda to.
Trapný palety tome můžu u tebe Filip
nebude trapný palety AD fi, d komunikace.
Můžeš, nebude to bůh ví,
jak na dlouho ten ten to review.
O trek jo.
No jelikož z velké části mirico a Martin
čech, tak jsme se akorát s Filipem,
když jsme se o tom bavili,
tak vlastně teď je to tak jako trošku
otevřené.
Jak moc vlastně je nás to ovlivní a kam
až nás to posune,
protože Filip bude muset asi.
Vykopnout nějaký tendr a je to takové,
jakože teďka.
Budem stát chvíli na místě,
než se v tomhle ohledu rozhoupem.
Jinak jako moc moc jiných novinek krom
toho,
že Filip teda stihl jenom ověřit to
jestli byly nainstalované ty zásuvky
datové, tak nic víc vlastně se neudal.
OK to znamená TDD.
Já jsem vám připosila email.
Poprvé.
No,
možná to to i tobě piva křečenová psala
instrukce teďka po těhle těch změnách a
šachách. Na koho se s čím obracet,
tak já ti ho přepošlu.
Tam jsou nějaký 3 jména,
tam jsou radekvít a nějaký ještě další jo.
Tak to proberu Filip ty adresáty.
Tam jsou lidi, na který si,
na který se můžeš obrátit, nebo Filip,
já mu taky přepošlu.
A to jsou jména teďka nově nově,
Jo.
který by vám s tím měly pomoci. Jo,
nepředpokládám,
že by si Filip kreslil sám.
Místní AT to asi úplně nereálný, jo.
Tak.
A tady ten termín posun se netušíte ještě
jo, to máte dotazník.
Jo jasně to jako Filip sepisoval s tím
záměrem,
že vlastně jako teď nedokáže odhadnout,
jak co bude dlouho trvat, když nevíme,
s kým to oni budeme řešit.
Jo,
já vám to pana pošlu a zkuste se na to
nějak podívat, tak?
Jo, jo jo děkuju.
No OK, no a ještě prosím tě řekni,
tady bylo 15 jo z télace bran to znamená,
ty brány ještě nebyly dodaný teda.
Ta integrovaná bránu.
Ne my jsme jenom měli tady pana stejskala
s tím,
že jsme si ujasňovali kde a jak to bude
uchycené. Vím,
že se tam Filip tam začínal řešit nějak
sasority. To přípravu toho uchycení ale.
Jo.
Teď jako nevím, jistě, ale myslím si,
že jako dokud mi tady nebudeme mít
připravenou tu infrastrukturu,
tak je zbytečné říkat inteklu.
Jo už vím, ona vlastně byla domluva,
že oni přijedou, až mi řeknem,
Jo.
máme nachystáno a tím pádem.
Toto je závislé na těch přípravách,
Jo.
takže tohle se ještě nestalo a bude to
asi chvilku trvat.
Autem paní se říká,
tady už byl nějakej pátek zpátky, že jo,
už tady bylo nějak předtím, že jo dlouho.
Ne to už taky nějakej čas.
No, jako určitě u nás nebyl poprvé,
ale tady tu schůzku jsme s tím měli.
Já vím to letí 2 týdny zpátky.
No si myslím, no si myslím.
OK dobře aleka,
jelikož to není pravda je to kritický,
tak asi jako v pohodě. No jo,
tady jenom prostě to to bouchat.
Riziko jo dobrý pošlu ty jména jo pošlu
ty jména koho se obracet tam to je krásně
napsaný.
Děkuju.
Tak.
Děkuji Lukáši dopravníková síť v
prašťanech cz c 4.
Jo tady.
Dopravníková sice podle mého soudu krásně
staví.
Aktuálně nevím o žádné vyloženě
komplikace, co se týká té fyzické části.
A takže jediné,
co asi teďka trochu může trápit Davida
jsou nějaké odstávky, ať už 1.
Která byla nebo 1, která se plánuje.
Kvůli napojení na SPL looku a pak na
budoucnost ještě čeká napojení na.
Dole na odtahu z tran zmrcal.
Zároveň.
Jsme začali.
Kreslit nebo rozpracovávat potom
následnou. My tomu říkáme vánočku,
ale prostě propojení.
Z tady tohohle odtahu na alza boxue s
walterem něco,
čemu říkáme pavouk a aktuálně to vypadá
na poměrně komplikované řešení,
tedy i drahé kvůli samozřejmě prostoru a.
Splatitosti té sítě,
takže ještě alternativně jsme vymysleli
nějakou jinou možnost,
jak tomu celému pomoct.
Ale to si musíme teďka ještě jako
vyčíslit, jestli je to dostatečná pomoc,
nebo nebo cesta vánočky bude nutná.
To je zhruba všechno.
Jo a samozřejmě ještě připravuju tu
softwarovou část,
kdy s Martinem jsme se už dohodli,
že se blížím na řadu VERUR frontě,
takže připravuji o zadání,
aby se to dalo integrovat.
V zásadě dle plánu.
Tady vidím takovej statem stavba 3 na
podlaží fáze 4 aktuálně zpožděná to platí
nebo ne?
I to je zpoždění.
Nebo ne?
Upřímně si nejsem jistý,
rozhodně tam není zásadní zpoždění,
jestli jako tečem 1 2 dny nevím,
nevím v tom detailu nejsem.
Tohle tohle tohle že je to trošku v
zákonu.
OK.
Kde vidíš to zpoždění?
A prosím tě a.
No to mám tady,
to by se stalo data z schůzek a takhle
ale jenom jestli o tom vidíš nebo nevíš
to bude se to jde podle plánu,
ale to asi není na tebe.
To je spíš na Filipa nevadí, já se zeptám.
Jako myslím si,
že to není ve významném skluzu,
takže plus mínus plánu.
Jo tak já jsem to do Filipa to je v
pohodě.
Hele a potom tohleto nějaká vánočka.
1 vánočka 2 to dokončení případných.
No to jsem teďka popisoval.
Já vím, ale ten termín,
případně dokončený, protože tady tady.
Já se ptám proto,
protože golive tohodle je devatenáctýho 6
těch dopravníků,
tak jestli to bude takže devatenáctýho 6,
nebo to bude po, nebo to bude separé.
To mě zajímá.
Bude to separé,
jakože my jsme tohleto vykopli jako 1
krok celého projektu do prvníkové sítě,
tedy ten odtah VPOZ nových prostor a
propojení s lupem a tak dál.
To se schválilo takhle, jak to je.
Následně budem pokračovat s transverseny
a tohle to,
co nazýváme třeba vánočkou nebo jinou
alternativou.
Je stejně u jiného teku zařazeno až po,
takže tam jako žádný termín není.
To je další kus.
OK tak já to budu muset s Filipem si to
ještě jako rozdělit.
Dobrý že ten golif je střeženej teda.
Jinak chápu.
A pak se ještě zeptám, prosím tě,
jestli víš,
jestli tušíš TDD něco o tý bangladáši?
Tady je 22 a dvacátýho 5 nějakej termín.
Potvrdit si potřeby v rámci Bangladéše,
jak tam nějakej status tady já.
Asi jsem slepej na ho nevidím.
Asi ten status není,
protože to je trošku složitější. My jsme.
V rámci nějakých ověřovacích výpočtů
vlastně došli k tomu,
že máme problém s primárně s tříděním.
A vymýšlíme varianty scénáře,
jak rozdělit a využít aktuální třídící
kapacity pro to.
Jsme rozjeli nějakou akci na.
Oživení ropase,
když to řeknu zcela zjednodušeně.
A výsledek tady k téhle aktivity může
zcela zamíchat kartama,
jestli tu Bangladéši potřeba upravit 1
nebo 2 způsobem.
OK.
Nebo jestli vůbec?
No dobře dobře,
a to 2 dvacátýho 5 to je reálný,
teda to když to poslouchám.
Ne není.
Ty jo tak to budem.
Ta aktivita kolem do pase bude trvat
mnohem déle a ještě nás teď čeká i
OK tak.
intralox je prostě na mnohem nižších
číslech než.
Než je takový ten příslib.
Technologie.
Přepíšu si poznámku,
zeptám se Filip patra ještě dobře OK?
Tak jo,
děkuju a mě to tady ještě tady k těm
converium jižním transforcoval todleto,
to je asi tady on hold. Zatím že jo.
On holt dejme tomu prostě to je v ve
frontě. Neříkám, že se tam nic neděje,
K.
protože už je nějaký mininávoz materiálu
a zároveň my hledáme způsob.
Jak.
Jak přeskočit nějaké fáze stavby,
tak abychom co nejdřív oživili vyloženě
ty transferce je vyloženě ten blok k napu
u autostoru a zjistili, jak jsme na tom,
abychom předešli problémům,
co byli minulý rok.
Ale tam je to samozřejmě trochu
komplikovanější,
protože t mečítá s nějakou instalací
čteček a asi není efektivní téma s učit
fungovat bez těch čteček. Takže.
Se snažíme, jak říkám, to nějak přeskupit.
Jo.
Já se tady škrtnu eviduji jenom milníky.
Stavební příprava je hotová,
nakopat hardware dopravníky rolery.
Na konci května se zatím tedy eviduji
takhle nějaký 2 otázky, jo.
Dobrý.
Tuším, že je to v pohodě.
Zeptám se.
No dobrý, tak jo,
zeptám se případně Filipa to ještě 14 dní
OK, děkuju, děkuju luky.
Martina nebo pik?
Jo hele co se týče robotiků,
ty hlavní věci,
který se staly včera včera,
došlo k předání nebo postupnýmu zaučování
robotiků na provozní lidi,
což tam má lidi.
Pod Davidem to řídil osobně Filip den
předtím nebo IV.
Pondělí jsme zaučovali nové chrášťanské
procesáky,
konkrétně péťo a kubulázničku na robotic
a určovali si tu strukturu strukturu toho
řízení a aktuálního.
Aktuálního flow,
jak budem pracovat s robobikem čili?
Provoz procesáci a čili.
Tohle se teďka nějak proběhlo,
to bylo to hlavní, co se událo.
Zahájili jsme nějaký 1 dekanting aktivity
společně s procesáky,
ať už chrášťanskými či slovenskými čili,
jak potřebujem opravit proces příjmů na
to na to,
aby ten robot jak měl hodně vysokou
úspěšnost picku,
a to jsou asi ty hlavní věci,
o kterých přemýšlím. Co se týče roboty,
mám jeho přebraný bod se reaktu a
postupně budem,
budem rozjíždět a robot do provozu
společně s lidmi vod.
Od Davida, aktuálně.
A dneska byl golifeda dneska že jo tohle
pěkný.
V podstatě ano, jo, dá se tak říci.
On byl jakoby už včera,
Nebo.
ale ale dneska by to mělo jít jako
oficiálně do provozu pod kubou a pod
provozním člověkem. Ano.
Takže chápu? Dneska je ten termín,
teda jenom pro mě,
že se to předalo vlastně do davidových
rukou.
Včera lomeno dneska ano.
OKA, to jsou taky prequity, že lidi viděj,
co mají dělat a podobně a nějakej trable
shooting. Když je to zasekne,
tak má někoho volat nebo jak to máte
Přesně tak.
nastavený.
Ale co se týče trouble shootingu,
já jsem sepisoval ještě tento týden celý
celý procesní celou procesní komfort
dokumentaci,
kde jsem vypsal vlastně veškeré vědomosti,
které jsem já.
Filip a robotiku měl přes používání
drobble shooting, jak řešit reporty,
tikety a tak dále.
Čili veškerý info by mělo být v rukou v
rukou hráčanských procesáků,
případně v rukou facility,
která by měla být seznámena s robotikem.
2 otázky, na to se ptám, tady vidím,
že jako pod sebe.
Ano.
To znamená,
co konkrétně vono jako pokračuje dál?
Ten projekt máme,
mám ho tady jako evidovat dál,
nebo mám zavřít nebo co s tím mám teďka
udělat?
Ale konkrétně jsem to převzal pod sebe z
hlediska z hlediska dalšího vývoje
produktu jako takovýho.
Filip měl za úkol ten produkt rozjet
dostat ho do provozní formy a předat ho
směrem jako k nám.
Jakožto procesnímu týmu. To se událo čili.
Filip se teď může soustředit na na jiné
nové projekty a už by neměl vlastně pálit
optimálně jako svůj čas na tomto projektu.
Takže,
případně příště se vám ptát výbušnin,
teda tebe jo nějak.
Ale je to nějaká,
je to nějaká přechodná fáze,
než si předberou úplně všechno?
Bude to nějak nějaký postupný přebrání
jako těch věcí,
který se maj udělat a tak dále?
Vzhledem k tomu,
že mám pod sebou ještě jiný projekty,
Jo.
tak na to nemám tolik času.
Kolik bych si přál čili,
musíme to dělat postupně.
Jo a to znamená,
že teďka po nějakou dobu tam ještě ten
ten hyperker chápu tedy ze strany sadaktu
je to externisty jako externí a ten hyper
provoz ještě tam bude ne nějakej čas nebo
z něčí strany procesáku nebo kohokoliv.
Jo ano ano přesně přesně, jak platíš.
Teďka bude nějaká doba přebírací mezi
mnou a Filipem.
Co se týče supportuser reaktu,
Jo.
tak máme dvacetičtyřhodinovou podporu v
rámci v rámci ticketů čili kdykoliv se
něco stane nebo něco nemůžeme vyřešit
sami,
tak jim můžu napsat ta reakční doba na
minutikru jsme ho zakládali,
byla asi nějaký 4 minuty,
takže odpovídá opravdu rychle.
Co se týče tohodle a co se týče supportu
provozu je tam,
Jo.
jsou tam procesáci aktuálně zaškolení,
který by měli.
Support toho provoz v jakékoliv situaci,
kdy je potřeba.
Aktuálně budeme pracovat jenom přes denní
denní režimy,
Jo.
což znamená od těch zhruba 8 9 do těch 16
17. Jak tam budou procesáci?
A já bych se měl dál řídit obecní
vývojovou frontu robotiků AA řídit
produkt to takovej.
Jo jo paráda. Paráda.
No dobrý,
tak tak to jsem se vidět no a hele a tím,
že to napíšu do confluence,
ty postupy a podobně tak.
Máš za úkol,
to nic to jako přečíst jo ty protesáci,
to je pro ně chápu to správně.
Ale je to obecně obecně procesní
dokumentace pro všechny,
koho by zajímala primárně je to pro
procesáky,
ať ví co a jak dělat a sekundárně to může
být aji pro lidi z provozu,
který se o to mají starat minimálně
určitě jako některé kapitoly,
které souvisí s provozem s provozem
stroje a ne tolik třeba jako z konzolí.
Mám tady prosím tak 1 bod je možné.
Nevím jestli úplně mimo je zpožděný
zpožděné doručení externích obrazovek
finální akceptace a předání do provozu.
To je blbost ne už asi že jo.
Poptám se na tohlencto přesně Filipa.
Co tím všechno myslel.
Taky.
Externí obrazovky.
Nakládají politic.
No no no tak jenom že tam mám poznámku co
mi napsal ten sledovatel společné řešení
externích obrazovek.
Vím moc se jedná,
tam se jedná v podstatě o to,
Ale no.
aby ten človíček,
který obsluhuje tu roupiky,
měl nějakou svýho pracoviště externí
obrazovku. Kdyby viděl,
když se jako přestane s tím roupikem a
viděl by, že k němu musí jít,
to je jakoby ten ten finální,
nebo to to ten ten flow,
kam se chceme dostat,
ale v jakým je to stavu aktuálně netuším.
Jo jo jo.
To se zeptám, Filipa.
Jo.
Ok tak to mi asi čiší,
že to ještě felik musí dopracovat,
dodělat dodat dodělat jako delivery.
Jak říkám, jak říkám,
to přebírání probíhá postupně čili,
něco už mám pod sebou něco ještě Filip,
takže nějak to bude ještě takhle
Jo jo jo.
organicky přebírat.
V pohodě.
To prostě jsme se o tom mimo mimo
dohodneme, jakoby jak to uděláme.
Tady potom administrativně na tebe nevím
na Filipa jak to, jak to bude evidovat.
Jo.
Ano.
OK.
Tak máme tady Michala michale vítej
zpátky můžeme na tebe.
Čau, děkuji a pardon za zpoždění.
Rma 1.
Teda máš po 1 hele vezmu to zase zavedu
mě tam, kde se nám to prolíná tak.
Co se týče infrastruktury,
tak tam jsme vlastně potom,
co jsme tam byli s Martinem AS mirikonem.
Tu situaci pak jako řešili,
co nastala a kompletně řešení
infrastruktury si přebírá Honza Šimáček,
který už se jak s miri koment tak s
cepenou potkal ve zdibech.
Dneska připravil zadání toho tendru.
Aktuálně je to na prokurtmentu kterej,
když nám dá OK,
tak tak oslovíme a počkáme,
na počkáme na to nacenění údajně jako
miricom. To, že tam figuruje stále OK,
ale už to půjde oficiálně přes tender.
To je ta hlavní změna,
která se tam jako odehrála. To znamená.
Ve finále se to podařilo vyřešit
relativně rychle.
AA neměli nějaké jako nabrat.
Takže toliko asi za za tu,
za tu infrastrukturu.
Co se týče toho rozvodu slačného vzduchu,
tak tam to Honza Šimáček řeší bokem skrz
skrz své kolegy,
zda by to zvládli tady udělat jako
svépomocí,
protože ten kompresor už tam máme,
takže teď je to jenom o vlastně jako
roztažení toho.
Toho vzduchu. No ty pracoviště,
kde jsme si vydefinovali,
tak pak tady pak tady máme to téma doprav
u.
Rma řešíme primárně ty DPD svozy ze zdi
do servisu tam po konzultaci vlastně v
pondělí s mírou evarem jsme došli k tomu,
že se chystá vlastně jako verze alza
trade 3 0, která by měla způsobit to,
že DPD nám bude do zdi bezdit standardně.
Tím pádem bychom se na tom jako.
Svést a využít to já teď zjišťuju jak jak
vlastně ten drop 3 0 má fungovat,
protože jsem o tom moc míry slyšel poprvý.
Míra mě odkázal na kačku kosťovou,
která to vlastně řeší, takže příští týden,
až se vrátí z dovolené,
tak si zjistíme nějaký detail o tom,
jak to bude a jestli to pro nás je
vyhovující.
OK.
Tolik KK těm k těm dopravám a potom z
pohledu z pohledu BOZP tak.
Byla vlastně jako ve zdivek verča vigris,
která nám tam vykreslila nějaké
koulníkové cestičky,
které tam dneska nejsou a měly by tam být.
1.
To znamená teďka Tomáš houda a snaží to
jako napasovat do toho layoutu tak,
abychom tam nedělali zase jako nějaké
výrazné změny a má to teďka vlastně jako
verča.
A věz k potvrzení,
zda je to jako za BSPOK, nebo ne?
No a.
Tady pro ty dopravy to máte konec května
1.
Z těch třeba ty jo 5 tady máte nějaký
schvalovačky těch úprav.
Jo.
Jo přesně tak do konce května potřebujeme
mít jako potvrzený,
OK.
že to všechno poběží tak, jak má.
Tak a pak tady mám.
2 2 otázky 2 otázky,
no promiň 1 otázka je.
To znamená tam,
že jo tam asi bude poptávat nějaký ty
cenovky a podobně,
kdy jin že ten květ ten konec května je
to nejpozdější, kdy musíte vědět,
kdo do toho půjdete?
Přesně tak jako za za mě jo vlastně jako
Pavla chudomelová s Honzou šimoráčkem mi
OK.
říkali, že?
To na tom zas tak jako nezáleží,
že my do toho tendru jdeme s tím že
deadline je 1 7 a ten kdo to zvládne k
tomu datu,
tak ten prostě pravděpodobně vyhraje,
takže tam by to mělo fungovat tímhletím
Jo.
stylem.
No ale samozřejmě asi nemůžeme přijít
jako poslední týden v červnu s tím,
že tam chceme něco dělat.
No to asi nefungovalo AA 2 otázka je ten
dodavatel kterej tam bude montovat tak
Jo.
jenom připojit? Já jsem si to říkal,
minule už musí vědět,
kdy ty stily budou a budou tam muset
fyzicky ty stoly stát,
nebo stačí jenom ukázat prstem tady.
Stoly tam fyzicky stát budou ani v
případě reversky, ani v případě rmačka,
protože my ty provozy musíme přestěhovat,
aby rovnou začaly fungovat na na na té 2
lokalitě. To znamená my tomu dodavateli,
až teda bude vybranej,
tak se konkrétně jako domluvíme,
jak to chtějí,
ale budeme jim tam vyznačovat vlastně na
zem polohy těch těch stolů,
aby oni tam udělali tu přípravu k tomu my
jsme to dneska už v rámci jako.
Jo.
Projektového meetingu probírali.
Rma tam s tím problém nebude.
Ještě to budu řešit s frantou srdečným za
za reverscu.
Nicméně tam bude hlavní otázka o
vyklizení toho prostoru ve chvíli,
kdy bude vyklizenej. Tak věřím,
že tam nebude problém to vyznačit.
Jo.
Jo a maj mají to kam dát jo maj to kam
dát jo a vyklízecí to ty ty věci.
Hele údajně údajně to vlastně to,
co tam teď je,
tak tam ani jako bejt nemá a je to prý
jako dočasná věc. Takže.
OK.
Měli by to,
měli by se s tím jako vypořádat,
no jsou tam nějaké lednice.
Víš, jak to bylo dočasný se stane trvalá,
tak jenom pozor.
Jo je mi to jasný.
Hele už jsem už jsem na to upozorňoval,
ještě si to budeme potvrzovat a teď
vlastně to, čím jsem ještě chtěl mluvit,
tak je obecně jako harmonogram toho
přesunu.
V příštím týdnu se musíme potkat tady s
Tomem s Tomášem houdou z emačka a vlastně
ještě s vasilem AS frantou,
abychom dali dohromady obecně jako
harmonogram toho přesunout,
protože v polovině června už budou jako
procesáci doprav potřebovat vědět,
k jakému konkrétnímu dni.
Maj ten zpětný tok nastavit do zdi.
Tím pádem my musíme mít rozhodnutí o tom,
kdy tam jde reverská, kdy tam d rma,
jestli tam půjdou ve stejný den, tak,
aby tam nevznikal nějaký jako velký
backlog těch věcí ke zpracování a aby se
nám nedej bože nestalo,
že se přestěhujeme AA zboží nám pořád
bude chodit do chrášťan,
takže tohleto potřebujeme teďka společně
jako zkorigovat a aby to jako vzájemně
sedělo všem stranám.
Jsem se právě zeptat.
Jak to budete přesouvat tak, že jo?
Tam přes to je asi nějaký KPI ukazatele,
tak nějaký sledování.
Jestli vám to poklesne,
nebo nebo tak něco kvalita a bůh ví kýho
čerta.
Jo my tam máme co se týče jackva,
tak tam je jako kvalita příjmu,
No.
reklamací a kvalita vlastně příjmu
odstoupení.
Tuším 2 nebo tří 3 dnů,
procentuálně to sledujeme,
takže tohle budem sledovat i nadále a
ideálně by se to číslo.
Po tom stěhování jako nemělo zhoršit.
OK.
Tak jenom, případně si pamatujte,
to jsme si třeba dělali my,
No.
že třeba očekáváme pokles kvality.
Tak jestli očekáváte někdy pokles
nějakejch čísel?
Třeba nevím z nějakýho důvodu dočasnej
Jo.
Jo hele to vyplyne to vyplyne z toho
harmonogramu,
víš jako.
Tak.
pokud se nám ho podaří vymyslet tak,
že tam jako nebude gap na to,
aby někde vznikl backlog,
tak nebudem očekávat ani pokles,
ale to teď nedokážu říct.
Dobře.
Jo.
Tak a ještě reverska,
tedy reverzní justika.
Reverská hele 90% toho, co jsem řekl,
tak se týká samozřejmě i reversky jediný,
co v rámci reversky ještě nemáme,
tak je vyznačený kamerový systém a tady
jsme trošku ve skluzu.
Nicméně jsem domluvený s frantou srdečným,
že ho do zítřka jdou dopoledne dodá,
protože ho Honza Šimáček potřebuje vědět
zase kvůli datovým zásuvkám,
aby aby je přidal ještě těch pár zásuvek
jako do toho tendru jo, takže.
Tohle tam potřebujeme doladit,
jinak už máme komplet layout má to má to
už už Honza Šimáček převzatý rozumí tomu,
takže tam to za mě běží.
Jsou souběžně s tím remáčkem.
A co se týče bere q tome,
jestli zase můžeš jako komentovat ten
progres od posledního týdne za sebe.
Prosím.
Jo tam už jenom akorát doplnit to,
že vlastně já stejně jsem jistý vlastně,
který den to bylo,
jestli už to padlo na této schůzce,
tak kdyžtak se budu opakovat jenom lehce,
tak vlastně měli jsme z it schůzku,
kde jsme si prošli to zadání.
Které jsme měli vymyšlené původně a
dospěli. Jsme teda k závěru, že?
Je to.
Je to věc, kterou si,
jako kterou vymysleli,
jsme jiný způsob bez vývoje,
který bude fungovat.
Použijeme na to aktuální proces
distribuce z příjmu a tady to,
co jsme měli vymyšlené,
tak si necháme jako v šuplíčku.
Až budeme tak nechci říkat,
jestli v brzké nebo v daleké budoucnosti
potřebovat skrz nějaké navazující procesy.
To upravit tak jako ta možnost.
Tady je ajťáci to viděli. Není to jako.
Nereálná představa jenom prostě těch
úprav je tam víc,
takže jsme to teďka jako.
Vyhodnotil jako.
Ne ne, ne nezbytnou úpravu,
takže našli jsme prostě způsob,
jak to dělat efektivně už teď bez úprav.
Mohli jste nám ten způsob popsat ten?
No jasně, tak.
Vlastně využili jsme nebo?
Přišli jsme s tím,
že jak standardně teďka funguje
distribuce z příjmu,
tak je to vlastně dost analogicky podobný
způsob, jak by jak mělo fungovat.
Tady toto s tím, že ve chvíli,
kdy to ta tříděna naskladní,
tak jim vyjede potvrzovat i štítek a bude
to fungovat prostě jako standardní
distribuce z příjmu a 3.
Dítě se to roztřídí a pak ta paleta se
pod paletovým štítkem pošle na ten cílový
sklad.
Kde to přes ty?
Distribuční,
respektive potvrzovací štítky budou
nasklňovat.
Potvrzovat, pardon.
Takže jako.
Je to nějak jako více vícepráce manuální,
více zásahů, nebo to je furt v pohodě?
Kompečita komplexita.
Nijak zásadně ne,
že to prostě fungující proces,
který funguje někde jinde,
tak jsme ho vzali 1 ku 1 a budeme ho
chtít použít na toto.
Hele a nebo náhodou IK takovým pod cílem?
Jako s optimalizovat rovnou přitom
stěhování a nemít to 1 ku jedný,
nebo jestli se mýlím.
No ne teď to nebude 1 ku jedný oproti
tomu jak je to teďka v chrášťanech.
Co.
Ano.
My jsme potřebovali vyřešit,
jak tedy ty vratky po nasklnění dostaneme
efektivně na 2 sklad,
kde se to bude potvrzovat,
aby s tím ten sklad byl schopný efektivně
pracovat.
Měli jsme vymyšlené nějaké to zadání,
které vyžadovalo úpravy v těch modulech
konzoli.
A místo toho jsme přišli se způsobem,
jak to dělat jinak už s existujícím
procesem, který se nepoužívá na reverse,
ale používá se na příjmu.
OK.
Asi jo no.
To znamená jako není to 1 ku 1.
Dobře.
Jako podle z pohledu reversky,
jak teďka je na chrášťanech,
ale využili jsme 1 ku 1 proces,
který se využívá v chráštěnech na nebo
obecně na příjmu jinde než na reverse,
ale ta pointa je stejná,
prostě naskladníme zboží a přes
distribuci to dostaneme na jiný sklad.
Dobře.
OK tak důležitý, že máte baclub,
nebo nějaký jako řeše funkční řešení a
nejenom ten vývoj. To jsem se trošku bál,
že na toho,
že spoléháte a dobrý to jsou dobrý zprávy.
Michaele prosím tě,
ještě ten harmonogram platí pro diversový
remáčkovi,
ten ten harmonogram příprava harmonogramů,
celý květen, že jo.
Ten ten ten musí být společnej,
protože rma je úzce závislý na reversce.
Tak já si tam přidám jenom jo jen takhle
pro knihovníka.
Jo.
To znamená,
že vy budete na konci května vědět,
co a jak AV červnu začínáte nebo te
finský přesun?
Ne, ne, ne to jako v červnu, v červnu jo,
ale na konci června. Jo,
Circa.
my si musíme říct,
jestli s jakým jakým stylem se to bude
Jo jo.
přesouvat, kdy reverska,
kdy je r má vždy zpětný tok a.
K.
V pohodě.
Takže jednatřicátýho 5 nebo kdy?
Z toho vznikne výstup.
Na tom měsíčním review potom tady třeba
nevím, kolikrát do 03-06 nám představíš,
Jo.
jak to máte namyšlený, jo?
Jo.
Super.
OK no tak jo.
Jo.
Na závěr?
Super.
A tím si nahrál poslední oslí můstek.
Jelikož uvolníte prostor že jo k nějakým
1 7, v ideálním případě nad pobočkou,
že jo teďka kde rma tak v pátek teda
pátek mám setkání,
máme setkání v nějakým širším kruhu.
Marek wigriss Ondra dane šterka,
inventury petr Hašek nebo lidi vlastně od
něj a možná davide napadlo tam taky
přizvat,
jestli jestli to nebo někoho od tebe.
Budeme se bavit nad tím,
jak ten prostor využít.
Jo je tady několik myšlenkových proudů.
Aha.
Tak, ale to bych počkal,
to bych počkal trošku i na inka,
Promiň.
To už proběhlo, ale.
protože my už to namyšlený máme.
Aha, no takhle já jsem chtěl říct,
že tady je několik myšlenkovejch proudů.
Co člověk takto názor,
co s tím onder má nějakej názor?
Míra má nějakej názor.
A tak dále,
takže takže tím cílem v pátek jenom se
jako potkat a říct si vlastně jako ty,
ty ty ty noty,
jako protože prostě někdy někdo říká 9 ta
montáže, dejme tam ten ******,
dejme tam inventury,
dejme tam facility jo a teďka vlastně je
potřeba dát tomu nějaký řád,
aby prostě to tady jako nelétalo firmou.
Jo, typicky prostě ty co znáš davide,
tak mým cílem mají ambicie si jako teda
sednou v nějakém fóru a říct si teda co a
jak.
Jediná myšlenka.
Aby se to nestala nějaká jako bramboračka.
Jo já ne v tomhletom ti rozumím prostě
jako my si pojedeme svoji tužku a pak
někdo přijde a to,
co my jsme tady oddělali,
No.
tak jako je k ničemu, tomu rozumím.
Víš, že třeba míra řekne,
já bych chtěl tu plochu po montážích,
to je 650m čtverečných.
Chtěl bych to na sklad že jo,
tak si dáme nahoru a teďka jo,
takže jenom to nějak dát dohromady,
tak já ti klidně připozvu,
jestli bys jo Tomáš za čerstla?
No a bude tam Hynek.
No nebude, právě to nemá dovolenou.
Aha.
Ale nemůžem prej čekat.
No, tak mě tam.
No to mi povídej.
Možná David naráží jako na to,
že my jsme vlastně tu schůzku.
Měli tady s Davidem AS Hynkem s Honzu
Zapletal s andou žižkou a tohle jsme
právě všechny tyhle úhly.
Pohledu jsme probírali,
dospěli jsme k nějakému jako konsensu.
Jak to teda využijeme a jako to,
co asi naznačuje David,
asi jako nebylo úplně fajn,
když bysme teďka jako chápu,
asi jste nevěděli, jako že tohle proběhlo,
ale asi by bylo fajn,
kdyby u toho byl ten Hynek,
pokud bysme něco chtěli dělat jinak,
než jsme se domluvili.
Protože.
Asi by mi to přišlo jako.
Takže já jako za mě.
Já bych třeba tejden počkal. Jo,
tady s tím dyť jako tohlencto nám zrovna
jako nehoří.
OK.
Dobrý,
tak já ještě dobrý díky zastupy 1 co si
to odnáším je pozvu tam Davida a pozvu
tam toma určitě teda jo,
jestli byste součástí diskuze AS Ondrou
se polí,
protože primárně to téma dostanu na
starosti.
Jo.
Ondra vodi v pondělí neznám historii,
jo vůbec nevím,
protože se to jako slepej k houslim,
takže pobavím se s ním,
Jo.
jestli nemělo smysl čekat na nelinka,
že on má nějakou svojí už rozpracenou
vizi.
No,
protože ihned to tam potom jde napojení
A počkat na něj, až se vrátí.
ještě na další a další věci.
Jo třeba o kterejch já nebo tom nevíme jo.
No a vidíte? No tak já se s ním dohodnu,
že?
Zase jinak nám nesděluje taky všechny své
myšlenkové pochody.
Přesně do noci s Ondrou, jestli počkáme,
až se vrátí,
a to téma nějak uchopíme trošku jako
dospělejc.
Tak.
To za mě by to bylo fajn.
Dobrý, ale děkuju za tu zprávu, to je,
to je velmi. Celé to jsem vůbec nevěděl.
Dobře.
Jo,
protože tam je potom nějaký vejtah a tam
potom budu.
Michal musí zajistit nějaký tady odpisy
předpisy toho toho výtahu sro a někam
nevím kam tak to taky s tím souvisí.
Dobroš.
Ale tak jo,
tak to byla asi poslední zpráva za mě.
Počkej jako že nám ten výtah tam
nezůstane.
Ne zůstane, ale odpisy víš dneska,
to je se odepisuje u nich.
Jo.
Jo ne dobrý, teď se mi trošku zastavil.
Ne bude tam spíš jenom finančně víš?
Ať to napadá na jiný call centrum.
Web.
Jo chápu chápu chápu účetní odpisy.
Ale ono to jde jako z jedný kapsy stejně
jako jo ale.
Jo akorát se to pře převede z 1 dělení na
2. Chápu.
Přesně tak přesně tak.
OK tak jo tak děkuji za tu zprávu.
Já si to tady napíšu a nějak to s Ondrou
proberu.
Tak to je všechno moc, děkuji za dnešek.
Za týden se potkáme znovu.
Děkuju.
Out.
Mějte se.
Taky díky ahoj.
Zatím ale.
Díky ahoj.
Ahoj.
Čau.